This is my smartphone
Hmm, I told you about Suning Day
[music]
rar
oha
Maybe this is my snow
[music] I'm coming I'll
wait for this stone and eat it haha
[music]
You can attack
today  I'm definitely not the number If you're on a
slope, don't let your guard down to the end nara
You're me too Yes I'll show you the optimism
Listen to the magic of time 21 times the top First donkey is black
[music]
[applause]
[  Music]
Alice, don't lose here If you lose here, you know
I want to get down All the amulets countdown wraps up 1
Get over it, this Groen
storage chori
dark emperor
What are you at the center
[Applause]
[Music]
Fun
It's the hottest battle, it's starting now
Paddle Road Dozen
[music]
New